a las vegas woman who's part of the
national nevada national guard says some
expensive military belongings were taken
right out of her storage unit it
happened yesterday in the northwest
valley arko mana shares her plea to the
thieves in a story you only see on 8
news now
the nevada army national guard soldier i
spoke with says thieves broke into her
storage unit here and stole more than 5
thousand dollars worth of military gear
she's now pleading for them to turn
themselves in i felt really violated
i've never been robbed sergeant renata
hunter is still in shock after some
unwanted guests visited this northwest
valley storage unit this week she gave
me this picture she took of surveillance
video showing someone carrying her
belongings out of her unit uniforms
rucksacks shoes boots
everything issued to you from the
military she says she wasn't the only
one the unit right across from mine was
also broken into sergeant hunter also
believes these marks make it clear the
thieves tried to get into more storage
units i've lived in this area almost my
entire life and i thought it was like a
super safe area but now i'm like not
feeling really secure and really safe at
all to prevent anything like this from
happening again she says the storage
facility just installed a different
brand new lock on her unit it cannot be
pried off sergeant hunter says photos
and messages from her time in basic
training were also stolen from her
storage unit perhaps even more than the
thousands of dollars worth of military
gear she wants those sentimental items
returned to her i can't replace those
pictures and those letters at all
sergeant hunter tells me she's filed a
police report and metro is investigating
reporting in the northwest valley orco
mana live local now
we also reached out to the storage
facility's corporate team for any more
information about the break-ins but we
did not hear back from them by air time